[Applause]
in our morning rounds a surprising new
study finds first-time mothers may be
able to safely shorten their pregnancies
to avoid complications the study in the
New England Journal of Medicine found
inducing labor at 39 weeks resulted in
fewer c-sections compared to waiting for
labor to begin naturally at 40 weeks
this contracts contradicts a long-held
belief that inducing labor leads to more
complications including c-sections a
typical pregnancy as we mentioned is 40
weeks researchers also found inducing
labor did not increase breathing
problems in babies and that lowered
mothers risk of high blood pressure
disorders our doctor Tara nurullah joins
us at the table Tara I was quite
surprised by reading this one expert
said this could be a game-changer is
this going to be the new normal going
forward well I think it's going to be an
option for sure and as you mentioned in
the past if a woman went to her OB and
said you know what can I have my labor
induced early the answer would have been
for most of them no let's wait until you
spontaneously go into labor because
there really was this belief that it
might increase these section rates and
increase complications to the baby and
the mom and so the fact though is that
about one out of four women end up
having an induction of Labor so
researchers really wanted to know what
are the consequences to the mom and the
baby
so they took two groups of women these
were low-risk women first-time moms and
one group they induced early at 39 weeks
the other group they allowed to progress
as they normally would to spontaneous
delivery and what they in fact found was
surprising that the induced group at 39
weeks had lower c-section rates had
lower rates of hypertensive
complications lower rates of postpartum
infection less labor pain and when they
looked at the babies because that's
important too there was really no
difference in terms of negative outcomes
or consequences to the babies really
like that less labor pain part but but
what is the magic number of 39 so 39
weeks is essentially considered
full-term and so after that point really
the benefit of having the baby and
longer is really not considered
significant and the lowest fetal
mortality is at 39 weeks so that's why
that really was chosen as the number and
we've seen more and more women have
c-sections in this country whether it's
or their doctor or elective or their
doctors telling them that they need to
because the baby's in distress could we
actually see that number lower and what
is doctors reaction to this we could and
right now really it's about 30% the
c-section rate that's very high it
should be almost half of that and you
know the issue about why c-sections
might be lower in the early induced
group we think could be a couple things
that are going on one the longer the
babies in the fetal size is bigger that
could lead to more c-sections also the
placenta may not work as well and that
makes it harder for the baby the fetus
to tolerate labor and then the longer
you're pregnant the more risk the mom is
for maternal medical complications and
also OB complications so certainly you
know this it makes sense that you may
have a lower c-section rate if you
deliver somebody earlier and c-sections
come with issues it is a surgery there's
risks of bleeding there's a blood clot
infection scarring to the uterus so that
in your next pregnancy
you put centum i implant in an abnormal
location injury to the bowel and the
bladder hysterectomy and list goes on
and on yeah not to mention that you have
to stay in the hospital longer so if
you're pregnant right now you might want
to call your doctor yeah certainly it's
worth a discussion I think that's what
ACOG and the Society for maternal fetal
medicine are saying that look based on
this study which they reviewed it's a
reasonable option for low-risk women to
discuss this with their dog
and have really a patient-centered
approach of shared decision-making
always good to have you here dr. Tao
Narula thank you very much